We have actually come across the notion of frames earlier,
when we were talking about production systems.
You may recall we had a diagram like this, where we had procedural, semantic and
episodic knowledge, and the working memory container structure like this.
You can see this is really a frame, here are the slots, here are the values for
the slots. We can think of these frames as capturing conceptual knowledge,
that is stored in the semantic memory. So let's take an example.
Suppose an input is a shark ate a frog. Remember the word ate there, and
that verb ate gets returned to working memory, and the entire frame for
ate gets pulled out. Once this frame is pulled out of semantic memory,
it immediately generates expectations. So we now know, that ate is likely to
have a subject, an object and location, perhaps time utensils and so
on. So we can ask ourselves the question, well what will go, under subject here?
What will go under object here? And in the sentence a shark ate a frog.
This frame tells us, what to look for. As a result of which, the processing is
not just bottom up, coming from natural language or the world in general, and
going into mind. Also, mind provides knowledge structures like frames,
which, structured knowledge representations, which generate expectations and
make the processing, partially top down.